bringing together the right data for the
right purpose has been a concept for
decades what started as clunky Cron job
turned into data orchestration and now
you're facing a pivot to Cloud daunting
not with Cloud composer stay tuned
while Legacy data orchestration tools
have made tremendous progress in helping
Enterprise schedule and monitor jobs to
support such a huge range of databases
and Enterprise applications they've also
started to weigh down companies for one
thing the threat of decommissioned
products lurks behind the corner people
are spending tons and tons of money to
maintain these licenses and in spite of
all that it's not scaling as you need
with your growing data one of the common
examples of one such Legacy
orchestration tool is autosis autosis is
commonly used across Financial Services
insurance and other company to automate
their workload it is typically used to
schedule data jobs sitting on premise or
on other clouds with heavy licensing
costs and skills needed to maintain it
you might be looking for another way to
modernize it well luckily there is a
solution that can give you 30 to 40
percent cost savings when you migrate
these data workloads on Google Cloud
let's take a look Cloud composer is
Google's data orchestration tool that
can easily run such jobs composer is a
modern workflow management tool with the
ability to author schedule Monitor and
manage these pipelines across Google
cloud and other Cloud environments it is
fully managed and based on Apache
airflow which is commonly used by data
Engineers for writing their pipelines
which gives them user portability and
freedom from login
as discussed earlier a composer
environment runs a fully managed
instance of Apache airflow in a Google
Cloud project the dags logs and plugins
are all hosted in cloud storage in the
customer project directed Earth cyclic
graphs or dags are a core concept of
airflow and hence composer dag is a
collection of tasks that you want to run
organized in a way that reflects their
relationships and dependencies a dag is
defined in a python script which
represents the DAC structure tasks and
dependency as a code here is an example
of a sample architecture
airflow scheduler takes action by
processing a DAC file with all the list
of tasks
this triggers multiple threaded workers
to complete these list of tasks
these tasks are based on python which
makes it easy to adapt to a technology
as it is commonly used as a programming
language airflow also provides various
operators for a lot of your common data
tasks which you can automate using
terraform or your favorite
infrastructure automation tool
automation on top of automation
airflow is already widely used among the
data engineering community but running
it on Google Cloud using composer gives
you a few more treats unlike the
licensing model you pay for what you use
and with our latest version to launch
you can scale your workloads up and down
as needed thus giving more bank for your
buck with integrated logging and
monitoring troubleshooting is much
simpler and efficient and with the
end-to-end integration with other Google
cloud services you can modernize or
migrate the underlying data workloads
from on-premise or cloud and build your
solution fully on our serverless data
Cloud migrating from Legacy workload to
a new technology in Cloud can be
challenging but with a managed solution
and a technology easy to adapt there is
a path for your migration in the next
video we will learn from one of our
technology Partners called Tech
illusions on how they help migrate a
complex autosis environment to Cloud
composer and providing youth savings and
efficiency in Google Cloud stay tuned
thank you